utah winning against the jazz losing
norman powell
early in that game and pascal siakim
smoked that time by russell westbrook
well i tell you what this is a good game
for the raptors to have to play right
out of the chute because
they create more challenges for your
defense they stretch out
as we hear the midway point of this
opening quarter
hardin deep three and it goes and james
harden can do that
rockets 40 and 24 overall 22 and 10 at
home
hardin on the inside we're scheduled to
face them on
april the 5th the raptors lost by 10
back in december 119 109.
and that was a lot of ben mclemore from
the corner three location he was eight
to 17.
you know words speak but actions speak
too and that's quite an action
driving through the state of florida as
the nba champs and
you know you're putting you're putting
your statement out there saying hey this
is what we believe in
on your back deck of your house well
you're by yourself
different 23-14
now wow and a deep three and it is
short-hardened with it
hardened westbrook tucker covington and
gordon starting five for mike d'antoni
and there's westbrook
right to the right three at the 438 mark
there was a double
technical on russell westbrook house
with the three-pointer that is good from
the corner
and norman powell
[Music]
lowry successful trip from the line he's
4-6
westbrook right look how quick and
explosive
he's ready to go 22 points combined hard
determined upon
when they are outside the bubble they
get tested
how often they get tested how many
negatives
they have when they have man advantage
opportunities
nice job pitching the ball ahead quickly
before the defense is set you get good
shots
harden the up fake and then gets right
to the basket
and as a starter as i mentioned earlier
in the broadcast he's been
lights out 27 games 18 plus points nine
plus rebounds hardin
with a three-pointer that is good and i
think you're going to see some
tremendous basketball from guys
particularly when they get themselves in
tip-top game shape
pardon makes a move